llegó el momento de economía aquí en
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio
daniela blanton daniela buena noche
bienvenida los altos impuestos están
impulsando argentinos a meryl a migrar
hacia uruguay daniela favor muy buenas
noches y le voy a decir porque en la
madrugada del miércoles la cámara de
diputados argentina aprobó y envió al
senado un proyecto de ley de origen
oficialista que graba las grandes
fortunas esto para sanear un enorme
déficit fiscal la iniciativa genera
controversia escuchamos un aporte
solidario como la solidaridad que
expresan los trabajadores de nuestro
país no es nada más que eso
[Música]
y del otro lado están quienes creen que
si se vuelve ley el expuesto empujaría a
las empresas a migrar a otros países en
realidad es un impuesto confiscatorio
que ya está regulado en otros impuestos
es inconstitucional
uruguay como bien decís tiene una
política de libre mercado mucho más
flexible con mucho menos impuestos todo
más simplificado lo tienen no sólo este
impuesto a la riqueza sino que no tienen
el impuesto a los ingresos brutos
no obtienen la cantidad de impuestos que
tire la argentina raúl y es que miles de
argentinos han llegado a uruguay
atraídos por excepciones exenciones
fiscales de acuerdo con un vocero del
gobernante partido nacional el vecino
país el lanzó este año una serie de
decretos para flexibilizar las normas
tributarias a las empresas se les ha
venido reduciendo la carga impositiva y
a las personas naturales se les ha dado
ciertas facilidades para obtener la
residencia fiscal por ejemplo les exigen
menos tiempo de permanencia y una
inversión más baja en propiedades para
acceder a este beneficio
esta tendencia migratoria representa un
enorme desafío para argentina que hoy
más que nunca necesita cubrir sus
necesidades fiscales así es daniela y
ahora cambiamos el tema porque en perú
ya es una ley el nuevo retiro anticipado
de las pensiones está fue así no el
único uno de los muy pocos actos
oficiales que alcanzó a firmar manuel
merino en su rápido paso por la
presidencia interina del país esto según
la prensa local citada por la agencia
reuters
en abril el congreso dominado por la
oposición
yo había aprobado un retiro de hasta el
25 por ciento del dinero que tuvieran
los ciudadanos esos fondos de pensiones
se alcanzaban a entregar hasta julio
unos 6.500 millones de dólares ahora se
permite un segundo retiro parcial que
será de hasta 4 mil 765 dólares pero
siempre y cuando el afiliado no haya
aportado más de 12 meses consecutivos en
chile- raúl están en el mismo proceso ya
se avale un primer retiro y el segundo
ya fue aprobado en cámara de diputados y
en las comisiones del senado para seguir
su trámite en plenaria del senado pero
el presidente sebastián piñera amenazó
con enviarlo al tribunal constitucional
así es añadir ya como también lo
veníamos adelantando en las emisiones de
noticias el boeing-737 37 podrá volver a
los cielos después de casi dos años de
revisión y un par de accidentes mortales
la administración federal de aviación de
eeuu autorizó el vuelo del 737 max de
boing
de todo el mundo dejaron en tierra a
este modelo después del accidente de un
avión de ethiopian airlines este
accidente ocurrió apenas cinco meses
después de otro de lionel en indonesia
con una aeronave de la misma referencia
entre los dos sumaron más de 340 muertos
pues no sé si las personas estén ya
confiadas en que montarán en este avión
pero esta entidad dice que sí
quiero decirles que estoy 100% seguro de
las acciones que hemos tomado y con los
cambios de diseño que se han
implementado en el 737 max pondría a mi
propia familia a volar en el mar ahora
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa daniela
indicadores justamente voy en que
comenzó la jornada con fuertes alzas y
terminó cayendo más del 3 por ciento la
misma tendencia se observó en el todo
wall street las bolsas europeas subieron
alentadas por los progresos en la vacuna
anti kobe y en américa latina' censos en
chile y en perú
para finalizar daniela que nos tiene
como cifra el día 12 277 billones de
dólares se disparó la deuda mundial de
estados empresas y familias por culpa de
la pandemia esto según el instituto de
finanzas internacionales esto equivale
al trescientos sesenta y cinco por
ciento del pib mundial así es daniela
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica a ustedes
también gracias continúe con nosotros y
buena noche
[Música]